Ralph breaks the Internet is bursting
with pop culture easter eggs and
references as well as in jokes poking
fun at Disney itself but on top of that
Disney also drops in some sneaky gags
making fun of their own fans
yippee chimera lovers it's Jan here and
in this video I'm going to reveal 5 ways
the wreck-it Ralph sequel totally trolls
Disney Marvel and Pixar fans my Funko
pops giveaway is also running on this
video so hit the bell and tap the gleam
link in the video description to enter
when vanellope arrives at the fan site
oh my Disney she discovers Groot taking
part in and asked me anything Q&A
session which is amusing because of
course all his answers are I am Groot
the first audience question comes from a
fan who has shades of The Simpsons comic
book guy about him and who manages to
create some ear-piercing
audio feedback on the microphone in his
desperate quest for an answer to the
following question in Captain America
the First Avenger red skull refers to in
Drasil the world tree garden of wisdom
and faith are we to believe sir that you
are descendant of that tree Groot
replies in his inimitable fashion and
the Marvel fan thanks him
of course Disney a poking fun here at
Comic Con Q&A s and also all of us fans
who love to spend time online connecting
all the dots between their movies and
coming up with sometimes wild theories
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe by
the way the obsessive Marvel fan in
wreck-it Ralph 2 is voiced by Jason
Mantzoukas whose character in the film
is called hey Nong Man which is a
catchphrase on the podcast comedy bang
bang which features Mantzoukas talk
about deep cut references after Disney
officially announced the movie's title
as Ralph breaks the Internet wreck-it
Ralph - back in March 2017 there were
loads of comments on websites forums and
social media suggesting that a better
title would have been Ralph Rex the
Internet has that better reflects the
original film when its title character
in fact it seems that the online laments
about the title was so loud that they
reached the wreck-it Ralph team at
Disney we decided to have a bit of
light-hearted fun by mocking both
themselves and their fans in the movies
trailer where Ralph asked the question
on everyone's lips shouldn't be Ralph
Rex the Internet yes since he is
wreckit-ralph oh yeah but break the
internet it's like a thing right it's
just wreck seeing it kind of sounds
better doesn't it you're not wrong
apparently the filmmakers did originally
consider calling the film Ralph Rex the
Internet but ended up going with breaks
the internet for the same reason yes
gives because that's the expression fix
our fans will doubtless have enjoyed
seeing many of their favorite characters
an easter-egg show up in wreck-it Ralph
- indeed Pixar gets its own section at
oh my Disney with the animation studio
signature desk lamp and luxo ball
adorning the area there are also cameos
by E from wall-e although from the good
dinosaur and Buzz Lightyear is there
meeting and greeting fans and Pixar's
brave Princess Merida also features in
the Disney Princess lineup when
vanellope breaks into the restricted
backstage area however the Disney
animators couldn't help themselves from
throwing a little bit of shade at Pixar
and its fans in that scene I give my
mommy a key she turned into a big beer
myojin traitor dear then that's not pure
mess I don't know where we can't
understand her she's from the other
studio ah now the princess scene does
poke fun at many of the Disney Princess
tropes we've seen over the years but
Disney does seem to be having a bit of
an extra laugh at Merida and Pixar I'm
sure it's definitely got nothing to do
with the fact that brave won the Oscar
for Best Animated Feature Film /
wreck-it Ralph at the Academy Awards in
2013 for anyone who found Merida
Scottish accent difficult to follow in
the trailer well brace yourselves
because Disney goes even further in the
actual movie as Merida's new lines are
delivered in an even thicker accent so
you're going to have an even tougher
time deciphering what she says in the
final film the entire Disney Princess
scene is of course very funny but some
Pixar in Scottish fans may feel a touch
upset and Merida's treatment by the way
if you'd like to check out all the other
Disney princess Easter eggs and Ralph
breaks the internet I'll add links to my
video on that at the end and in the
video description
okay spoilers ahead for the end credits
which are basically just jokes so no
story spoilers if you think back to the
first trailer Disney release for Ralph
breaks the internet you'll likely
remember it ended with that poor
exploding bunny in the pancake milkshake
game perhaps we might want to try
putting the Kitty Brown Alya
no the kitty gets the milkshake the
bunny gets the filmmakers include a
deliberate nod to that horrifying
trailer scene in the new film when Ralph
makes a video unboxing a pancake
milkshake fun set however by the end of
the movie proper there's still no sign
of any exploding bunnies just a few
images of the game's cute cat and rabbit
in the fancy credits so that trailer
scene must have been cut from the final
film you think to yourself but you're
wrong Disney has actually been trolling
you and they reveal their master prank
in a mid-credits scene the scene starts
with the mother asking her daughter if
she enjoyed the movie and the little
girl replies well there was a scene in
the trailer that wasn't in the movie and
that makes me sad so the mum suggests a
little girl play a game to cheer up and
that game is yes you guessed it pancake
milkshake cue the previously missing
trailer segment with Ralph and vanellope
force-feeding pancakes - a helpless
bunny in a scene reminiscent of mr.
creosote in Monty Python's the meaning
of life and Violet Beauregarde and Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory the
wreck-it Ralph c14 were obviously having
a bit of fun with their fans especially
the kind of movie lovers you know the
ones you enjoy finding out all about
scenes or characters deleted from movies
as well as alternate endings and any big
story changes during the filmmaking
process
well played Disney well played if you
stick around till the very end of the
credits Disney has got another
ridiculous surprise for you that ties in
perfectly with the movies online setting
yes after all the credits have rolled a
voice announces and now an exclusive
sneak peek of frozen - but if you think
your patience is going to be rewarded
with a special glimpse at the frozen
sequel then think again because the
voice also tells you to click here and
although you'll hear some brief
orchestral music the screen quickly
changes to Ralph's singing and dancing
along to the chorus of Rick Astley's 80s
hit never gonna give you up complete
with backup dancing from fix-it Felix
and shanks crew
yes that's right Disney just performed
that classic prank eonline
bait-and-switch the rick roll on us all
and as if ralph rickrolling us wasn't
enough the video game fat guy also talks
directly to the audience the way Ralph
breaks the fourth wall in this post
credits scene and tells us there's
really no reason to stick around in the
cinema any longer is a nicer March to
John Hughes classic 80s comedy Ferris
Bueller's Day Off which also received a
tribute in the first deadpool movie of
course this isn't the first time that a
character in the Disney stable has
trolled those of us who stay right
through the end credits I'm looking at
you Captain America and spider-man
homecoming sometimes patience is the key
to victory sometimes it leads to very
little and it seems like it's not worth
it and you wonder why you waited so long
for something so disappointing now what
were your favorite moments or jokes in
Ralph's breaks the Internet let me know
in the comments below and remember to
subscribe and click on the gleam link in
the video description for a chance to
win an awesome wreck-it Ralph Funko pop
congratulations to the winners of my
Bohemian Rhapsody giveaway send me an
email with your details so I can get
your prizes sent out to you tap left to
check out all the Easter eggs and gags
you missed in the Disney Princess scene
what's happenin you're sure to LIKE and
if you enjoyed this remember to share
and leave a thumbs up for more videos
like this thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers